[Music]
well
there is this man who has been dubbed
being dad have you heard about him being
deaf yes
i've heard of dub being dad hashtag bean
dad
was this like trending topic on twitter
recently
and it's all surrounding this one guy so
he's from seattle he's an
indie rocker and podcaster named john
roderick
he is in the band the long winters
and so what's your favorite song yeah
christmas which album do you like the
best
thank you i don't know any of those
songs so uh
so anyway he went on twitter this is
what he looks like
he looks like john goodman he's a
handsome dude kind of like russell
crow-ish
he looks small very much russell crowe
if russell crowe and john goomba had a
baby and george lucas
oh georgetown oh yeah he's got the he's
like the handsome
skinnier steven spielberg he's about to
take off his glasses
too ridiculous and the colonel but the
younger version oh well
very much yeah so he went to twitter and
he posted a
very lengthy story
a [ __ ] ton of tweets it must be worth it
and it has been dubbed being dad
and he has been dub being dead right
because the story because of the story
so what the story is i'll just read the
first tweet and that's it
uh and i'll tell you the rest um so it
says so yesterday my daughter
nine was hungry and i was doing a jigsaw
puzzle so i said over my shoulder
make some baked beans she said how like
all kids do when they want you to do it
so i said
open a can and put it in the pot she
brought me the can
and said open it how so then he goes on
this really long telling of the story of
how
he he just made her look at the can
opener look at the can
and force her to figure it out on her
own to the point where it took
six hours for her to figure this out and
as he's telling me the story
like i said he had already mentioned
that she was hungry right
so a lot of people reading this story
they got triggered from like their own
emotional trauma
from their parents and how horrible
toxic parenting
um they've had like they've had that in
their own childhood so this went viral
and calling him like a horrible dad
very [ __ ] abusive what the [ __ ] your
daughter
you don't think it's abusive no i don't
because i don't at all because i'm just
like
you like how old is this kid nine nine
fourth grader you don't know how to open
a can
i'm like man maybe i failed as a parent
you know what let's figure this [ __ ] out
that's the attitude is it should be him
being like i felt as a parent i should
she should know how to do this so let me
show her
then if she asks him tomorrow he's like
well we should we went over this already
and you should know
but clearly she doesn't know how to open
a can and and he's just making her feel
stupid and stupid and stupid for six
months if it takes six hours then yeah
there's something else going on here
dude what if you've never
no i'm with you i'm with you yeah
exactly the kids shouldn't be blamed if
they weren't
taught how to open a can i 100 agree he
said it took six hours
so you can't show her the answer like if
i think six hours is pretty gnarly
yeah that's it okay that's extreme yeah
and also
she he said no one's eating anything
until you get that candy
but i don't know what the tweets are and
what what are they is he explaining the
process like
excruciatingly explaining it i don't
know what the tweets are i also don't
know is the kid
like crying this whole time or yeah i
don't know the interaction that went
down
he doesn't explain the interaction and
so what he says is like
he he's so he was viewing this from his
own
perspective and assuming everyone knows
his personality which
he claims that his fans know that he
does this like
bad dad bit on his podcast and that
it was supposed to come off as like as a
bit and
so it ended up like backfiring for him
because
if you read the whole the whole story
yeah i read the whole story
wait so did it really happen or he's
making this up i'm so confused
this story really did happen but the way
that he wrote it he purposely wrote it
in a way where he was like being like a
stern
like that's not the real part the
incident is real but just the details
he skewed even if you told me he did it
nicely for six hours
i would be like well so that's pretty
gnarly i didn't catch three times
yeah there's um he has a lot of patience
i just saw
what a patient man six [ __ ] hours but
if
i give up after one minute if it takes
him six hours to teach somebody how to
open a can and put and cook some beans
i i think he has he's a very bad teacher
six hours yeah
that's ridiculous he has a lot of time
i'm gonna read to you guys this apology
okay
well also i put myself i put myself in
the kids shoes
and so um because i automatically assume
that
the kid is me and i'm like oh i could
totally have dragged that [ __ ] out for
12 hours like my dad wanted to
teach me something but i really wanted
my dad to do it for me
i would just keep playing dumb and dumb
and dumb and dumb and dumb so i also
don't know what kind of kid they're
dealing with
you could see in the story of the way
he's painting it like the girl like she
was trying to figure it out and he was
he's even putting things like
yeah like she got like uh she got
certain things right like she's twisting
the mechanism and like she
he's trying to get her to think like
really about the engineering behind a
can opener
and but he was like so she's so close
like she just needs to get the latch
onto the can and like he's like i'm
telling you he's
really going through this whole story
like in excruciating detail
how come he didn't have that the one
that does it already for you
i know right you put it in the machine
because he calls himself in the tweets
apocalypse
dad so like he wants to have cause you
need a can opener and a [ __ ]
apocalypse
he's like i can't open up my cat dad
there's no cat opener you taught me
wrong tools
or put the camera in the microwave and
put it on 50 and watch it explode or
something
does he have a microwave if he's
apocalypse dad he shouldn't
so i'm gonna read the apology and it's a
little lengthy so bear with me it goes
an apology hi i deactivated my twitter
yesterday in a panic i had to reflect on
what i'd done and the hurt i caused and
my mind was clouded by an unprecedented
flow of new information i want to
acknowledge and make amends for the
injuries i caused i have many things
to atone for my parents story my
parenting stories
insensitivity and the legacy of hurtful
language in
my past oh because i forgot to mention
people went to his twitter account and
dug up
anti-semitic stuff oh [ __ ] a whole bunch
of other
bad things that he said in in the past
um so he says
in my past are both profound failures i
want to confront them directly my story
about my daughter and the can of beans
was poorly told i didn't share how much
laughing we were doing how we had a bowl
of pistachios between us all day
as we worked on the problem or that we
both had a full breakfast together a few
hours before her mother was in the room
with us all day and
alternately laughing at us and telling
us to be quiet while she worked on her
laptop
we all took turns on the jigsaw puzzle i
framed the story with me
as the [ __ ] dad because that's my
comedic persona and my fans and
friends know it's a bit what i didn't
understand when posting that story was
that a lot of the language i used
reminded people
very viscerally of abuse they'd
experience at the hand of a parent
the idea that i would withhold food from
her or force her to solve a puzzle why
she
cried while she cried or bind her to the
task for hours without a break
all were images of child abuse that
affected many people very deeply
rereading my story i can see what i'd
done
i was ignorant and sensitive to the
message that my
pedent pedant pedantic without the
dad comedic persona
was indistinguishable from how abusive
dads act talk and think i woke up
yesterday to find that i had become
bean dad i was a locust for a tremendous
outpouring of anger and grief it took me
hours to fully grasp i reread the story
and saw clearly that i had framed it so
poorly so insensitively being dead
full of braggadocio and [ __ ] swagger
was
hurting people i had conjured an abusive
parent that many people recognized from
real life
i'm deeply sorry for having purchased
precipitated more hurt
in the world for having prolonged or
exacerbated it by fighting back and
being flippant
when confronted and for taking my
twitter feed offline yesterday
instead of facing the music i wish the
parents i modeled didn't exist i wish no
one had to grow up with a parent who
tortured them physically or emotionally
i would never intentionally make light
of those experiences and i'll never
underestimate again the pain
i caught i can cause with some poorly
chosen words by my acting defensively
when challenged
he goes on to talk about the
anti-semitic stuff um
and then guys it was five years ago it
was okay to hate jewish people right
but obviously i regret those things and
then so he ends up saying now
i'm a middle-aged man i mean i'm a
middle-aged middle-class straight white
male and i tried to be cognizant of that
when of that and of the responsibility
my privileges entail in everything i do
in this case it was precisely my
privilege of not living in an abusive
family of not being a member of a
community that routinely experiences
real trauma that caused me to so grossly
misjudge the impact of the language i
chose i have a lot more reflecting to do
in the coming days so i'll be taking a
hiatus from my public life
to let some of these lessons sink and i
apologize to my partner's friends and
family for all the people
that affected it's hard to do comedy on
text
because if people don't know you and
it's on a public platform
and they can just read it for face value
and if they don't know the background or
whatever they're just gonna
read it and go well [ __ ] this guy's
an [ __ ] to his kids
yeah if you're saying it's a true story
like your kid didn't eat for six hours
until she could figure out how to open a
can
then it's like that's much different
than we all shared pistachios and tried
to figure out a can opener together
it's way different i'm also ignorant to
this stuff um but
is it his fault if like i don't know
twitter is or maybe he has a character
on twitter or something and that's the
character writing it is it his fault
that other people are triggered by what
he's writing
it's not his fault but he's
understanding how
the negative effects because he didn't
understand the consequence
of uh saying what he wanted to yeah so
like he was doing his bit but he didn't
realize like if he knew
that it could hurt people he wouldn't
have done his bit so but then there's
other people out there that's like i
don't give a [ __ ] i know that it's gonna
hurt some of you but this is my bit
but then he's taking the approach of
saying like well if i ever knew that it
could hurt these people
that's not what i'm about i'm not gonna
do it that style yeah because
i do agree too like when it comes to
doing your own creative work right yeah
you have to do it unapologetically
but you can't you have to also be aware
of the results of your actions like if
you're going to be able to accept
what's going to happen you're coming
your way you can't get mad that people
are mad
and then you're just like well you don't
get the joke and it's like well
it's all about execution i think that if
he was on his podcast which it sounds
like he has like a fan base on his
podcast if he did this bit there
then everyone gets it because they're
like oh we get when he's being serious
and when he's not being serious
but twitter is such a general like a bra
it's writing versus you can't hear the
tone
you don't know what yeah and it gets
viral so fast because people share
things and then
it goes to people who don't know who you
are and they don't know the history of
your
content and all that stuff well there's
also just people i mean dude there's
so many [ __ ] up things out there that
like people can see something on
facebook say
and go oh my god this kid is being
abused here so it's like it's kind of
like that where people are just seeing
this and going
is a child being abused at home like
that's [ __ ] crazy and who wouldn't
think that way if they
read something like that not knowing all
this other [ __ ] but also you also can't
control the projections of people
because when i heard this i'm like damn
he spent six hours
giving her that attention to teach her
something i didn't hear abuse you heard
abuse
because my baseline is is real abuse is
my dad would get frustrated in 30
minutes and beat my ass but don't call
it real obvious you've got
physical abuse this is emotional trauma
it's different abuse
logical abuse yeah so i got the
emotional psychological and the physical
on top of it so just because the
physical is me mistake doesn't mean it's
not abuse i would okay not real then
it's more intense
because there was extra consequences
that stacked upon just emotional
right so then the severity of it was
like
my baseline is much much lower to where
other people can see this and be
triggered and say this is exactly what i
went through where i
i see the grass's greener effect and i
see this and i go oh that's [ __ ]
awesome
well you're seeing yours it's not as
nuanced they're giving
the dad's giving her attention this
whole time but then people have actually
gone through this type of trauma like
they're not getting attention from their
parent they're just
i'm not rewriting the fact that i'm not
i'm not discrediting the fact that it's
abuse for people
all i'm saying is a different
perspective because if you've
um gone through a situation where
you feel that your parents threatening
your life that is a different form of
abuse
where you hear things like this and you
go oh cool he gave
them attention not not realizing that
that's
also harmful you see it as that's better
and also i think the point
that he's making is also when there's
text
everyone's projecting something else
right for me i automatically projected
myself because as a nine-year-old i was
a [ __ ] [ __ ]
so if if my parents are trying to get me
to do something i don't want i'm like
you want to go to war we'll drag this
out for three days straight if you want
so i so like i'm like i automatically go
oh [ __ ] this is a little genius at work
it's a little like harley quinn at work
that's dragging something that can take
30 minutes she's dragging it to six
hours so you were like poor dad
yeah i'm like how lucky she got
attention
he's like how abusive so i was just like
man this is crazy that like
someone's writing uh like everyone can
view it from completely different
i didn't even get the six hour part so i
was like tight it's [ __ ] he's
teaching this kid how to fish yeah like
how to like
take care of themselves yeah it's crazy
but then the problem i think is when
you have a consensus of people who
believe that it's one way and only one
way
like they already made up their minds
that this man is a horrible abusive
human being
and i think when you pass judgment like
that without even knowing the whole
story that's what's [ __ ] up
100 yeah but it's easy to do because
it's like on social media especially if
everybody is
confirming your thoughts yeah yeah
with the past tweets like here's more
evidence of him being a shitty person
it could it escalates quickly yeah
that's why i think
it's just dangerous right now to play
with anything controversial or dark
humor or anything like that
yeah because it's just oh man it's just
[ __ ] up
[Music]
[Music]
you